let's continue on the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 our next caller is from the 4
for 3 area code caller from for 4 3 tell
us who you are where you're calling from
and what your question is today hi my
name is dougie I'm from White Plains um
I'm just kind of curious I don't listen
to the show very often but I'm kind of
curious like your thoughts on the kind
of rhetoric about the Democratic Party
not having any M message gand we are not
Trump uh I think that's kind of unfair
to think that the Republicans really
have much of a message in news and I so
it's my question well listen I've been
critical of the lack of messaging from
Democrats I think that there are
elements of a platform from the
Democratic Party but there's a couple of
different problems number one is that
there is a sort of rift that has taken
place on the Left since the election
part of it is because there are factions
that are divided over whether Trump
Russia determines the legitimacy of how
good or bad of a candidate Hillary
Clinton was or whether Bernie got
screwed by the DNC and I've talked
extensively about how I think that that
split is really counterproductive
separately however earlier this week I
reported about how donors are already
loving reportedly kamila Harris the
California senator for 2020 and what a
disaster it is that you already have
donor excitement and money pouring in to
Canela Harris when we're not even
thinking about the 2018 midterms which
is really where Democrats need to be
focused focusing right now excuse me and
part of that is having a coherent
platform so I think that Dougy
it's a fair criticism that the
Democratic Party is not on message in
terms of a platform at the same time I
don't believe that it's just the time to
throw the Democratic Party into the
trash because let's be honest we all can
get behind the idea of third parties but
until we have real campaign finance
reform and I would argue ranked choice
voting you're not going to see at the
national level third parties may
make a significant impact so I think
there's fair criticisms Dougy of the
Democratic Party that are not hyperbolic
okay all right dougie thank you very
much appreciate the call important and
relevant topic got to be thinking about
2018 though please we've got a don't
don't lose sight of the ball at this
point